kim kardashian is ready to move on from
her marriage to kanye west
in fact a source tells et that right now
she doesn't want anything to do with him
i'm just rolling with it the 41 year old
reality star filed for divorce from the
father of her four children north saint
chicago and psalm back in february 2021
and the process is still ongoing
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
after the skims founder noted in recent
court documents that she does very much
desire to be divorced a source tells et
that kim is just trying to focus on
herself her kids and her work quote the
back and forth with kanye has been
incredibly draining and upsetting for
her she has been trying to move on with
her life and take care of herself and
kanye's actions have made it difficult
to do so
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
of course a source previously told et
that the grammy winner still has hope
that he and kim will get back together
it's a sentiment he expressed recently
on instagram writing god please bring
our family back together and on stage in
december when he changed the lyrics to
his hit run away
but our source says kim only wants a
healthy co-parenting relationship with
her estranged husband and other than
that she doesn't want anything to do
with him right now it is what it is
meanwhile kim is leaning on her
boyfriend pete davidson e.t source says
he's been supportive of kim and they are
staying positive about their
relationship and enjoying how things are
going i love that energy in my life
quote pete doesn't want to be involved
in the drama so he deleted his instagram
account
you know social media is such a great
tool but of course you need boundaries i
think everyone does
of course the 28 year old saturday night
live star deactivated his account
earlier this week after fans theorized
that his lincoln bio which directed
followers to a clip to the 1982 film the
king of comedy was a not so subtle dig
at his girlfriend's ex
better to be king for a night than
schmuck for a lifetime
this all comes after the 44 year old
rapper trashed kim's nubo in several
since deleted posts to social media and
let's not forget this diss on yay's
track easy
just so i could beat pete davis
but a source previously told et that
pete is trying to stay out of the drama
between the former couple
adding that he's been trying to
disassociate from kanye as much as
possible and ignore his rants quote pete
knows it's not his place to be too
involved even though he is being dragged
through the mud he doesn't care he just
wants to be there for kim and support
her he genuinely cares so much about her
and their relationship
[Music]
you